We talked the last time I
talked to it a little bit about,
um,
this,
this whole issue of the
imagination that Dante places, uh,
along with it and definition
of love and the love is the,
the,
the power that governs,
that shapes the moral world of purgatory.
Um,
last time we talked about this tool for
psi of canto 17 to four side of this
center really makes, makes a
center kind of ellipses as it were,
right between imagination and love.
Uh,
love is attached to the,
it's,
it's joined to a theory of free
will because it's by choice,
uh, because of our choices that we
can be held accountable for. Uh,
the actions that we engage
in loving wrong objects,
loving too much or loving
too little. The, the,
some of the problems I think,
uh,
stemming from a certain misunderstanding
about the imagination that Dante should
place the imagination of the center of
the poem should really not surprise you.
He's a poet and he thinks that imagination
is indeed the path that he has to
take in order to come to any, uh, any,
any form of knowledge. It's only
through the imagination. It's not,
that does not exclude rationality,
but that's the discourse of philosophers,
that discourse of theologians if you wish.
And he places the imagination as his way.
Uh, and then from that point of view,
who can even challenge some ideas of,
uh,
uh, the superiority, let's say, of a,
of a rational argument
over the imagination.
Imagination is the weapon of the port.
How,
with what kind of
attributes does he invest?
The margination it's tied to memory.
The port,
the canto 17 begins with an
apostrophe to the readers memory.
Uh,
it's,
it appears as in the feminine imaginative,
uh, the, the, in, uh, in, uh, uh, the,
the Dante silencing
the term vis a vis the,
it has a sort of force imagination.
It's moved by something else.
Dante does not decide whether it's the
having of the stars or comes from inside
us. Uh, but he has a particular
power is strange power.
It comes like a thief in the night.
It robs us of, uh, uh,
the, the any degree of, uh,
of, uh, uh,
consciousness about the world
outside of us. Uh, uh, and,
and just justice, memory, uh, this
lodges, uh, you know, the, the, the,
the description of memory at
the beginning of canto 17,
it's her mammary that it has an incredible
memory as a form of the imagination.
As you know, uh, memory and
imagination are connected. The,
the,
it's a form of the imagination,
but it's a memory that has
the power to move up and down.
The text evokes the Alpine
heights and the depth of the mall,
the mall.
It talks about a form of blindness.
And yet it creates
vision, uh, uh, memories,
a figure of time.
And then the,
the whole passage is described in terms
of space as if it imagination had the
power to dislocate us from
where we think that we are.
This is the point,
and it's not an unusual polling for
Dante to make sensitivity is this is the
poetry of exile.
The poetry of a man who thinks
that he's a stranger. Well,
living on earth,
a man without a clear sense
of where he's home, maybe,
uh,
he is,
this is the poetry rooted in the
consciousness of homelessness.
So imagination is an extension.
And internalized,
internalized version of
this sense of homelessness,
but it has a power and that power that
doesn't seem to be able to be that a
power that can cannot quite big
campaigns or coerced within definite,
uh, parameters of a conduct. In fact,
this insistence on the imagination,
I'm going to be recapitulating the
things that maybe I thought I said the
probably I didn't say last
time between on the one hand,
the scene of wrath, which is a
form of madness. This will say,
uh, he's seen that eclipses the
powers of reason. That's anger. Uh,
and on the other hand, uh, at
this discourse on love, okay,
so this is really what I was saying,
Dante and the stands.
And there is an imagination which
cannot quite be held in check.
And yet the whole point of the poem I'm
talking whenever I'm talking about that
poem I, I point out some seemingly
insignificant details like, Oh look,
this is a symmetry here between Canto
six of him, fair, no canter's each of of,
of purgatory or whatever.
Uh,
to indicate that it is a poem built with
a precise principle of all the in mind.
Not only it has all the in its,
in its technical execution,
it has all the also as a moral problem,
it's all about ordering the
appetites or during the will,
but at the same time alongside with it,
and this is the complexity and
the beauty of dentists texts.
There's another argument that almost
questions makes us to, makes us,
forces us into thinking
that there are some,
some elements that seem to be left out
of this fabric of order that Dante has
woven or if you like the metaphor has
built the architecture that he has built.
Let's see how this arguments really
containers that that's the end of the,
of the story.
This is just a stage in his saw movement
of soft knowledge and knowledge of the
world. In fact, Ken to 18, we
are now moving into a different,
different moral realm.
Uh, it's a moral wrong.
Actually now we are moving
toward this hill called Ah,
what Dante and medieval
theorists of vices core Acadia.
Uh,
a kid is a Latin term,
which in English we can describe it would
describe as a soldier of despondency
as they sold to in decisiveness,
sluggishness, Straw. Sloth.
That's it. That's this. The, the uh, uh,
and they thought if you are interested
in knowing more about what the Middle
Ages thought about this, this, uh,
scholar when's up wrote
a book called Arcadia,
exactly what they both in English,
medieval literature, Dante, et Cetera.
Another are their issues.
What most precise and how can we go on
understanding this question of Acadia?
It's in a sense the pattern or
the inversion of contemplation.
It's really tied to a sense
of loss of the outside world.
Cadia describes the condition of the mind
that has found itself indifference to
the objects of desire.
It really is a crisis of desire.
One finds the objects. That's
the, this laws to sluggishness.
The decisiveness of the mind. It is.
If the objects of desire were, um,
had lost their consistency,
their attractiveness,
their luster, you know, you,
you just don't care. It's
the problem. Then the, the,
the so called noon day a devil,
the temptation,
the temptation of the Hmong, that's why
I call it her paralegal contemplation.
It's the temptation of that the monks
experience in their clusters when they saw
to find that the whole idea of
turning their minds to the divine is,
is no longer or provisional
reprep perhaps is not, uh,
uh, appealing. It's, it's the, uh,
the loss of appeal of anything outside of
oneself and indicates a kind of, uh, of,
of both intellectual and
dreamy sort of condition.
And that's really what I want
to talk about now. 10 to 18
is the most intellectual of cantors
in, in, in, in, in purgatory.
Dante phases,
a theoretical issue.
He's talking to Virgil and this
theoretical reissues of Kantar 18,
uh,
flow out of the problems that we
have had in discussing canto 17.
As you know, the, we're talking
about imagination and love it.
There is an imagination that
somehow is vagabond. It's a thief,
breaks out of any particular
confines in this lodges us,
it picks the ground out of our own
own certainties about the, the,
the way we see the world.
Remember that the image that would
with which can two 17 starts we done to
places as in a world which you said
at the twilight there's no real light.
It's all foggy.
And then all of us haven't,
we do see something and it's unclear
whether we see something and because of
their lights that comes from
within us memories for instance,
that's highlight we carry
within us confused as they
may be or some other kinds
of consciousness or intuition.
So that's really that the discourse of
the imagination and that this large,
some of us here that made it
a little difficult to, to uh,
try to get hold of grasp. It can't,
it has the same problem in Canto 18.
Can't wait til begins with a
question that he asks of Virgin.
You are talking about love. We are
talking about this inclination cans,
the whole theory of love in canto 17.
Uh,
he says,
master
my site.
This is can't wait.
In the very beginning he saw quicken in
thy light that has a certain clearly all
that they word set forth
and explain and explain.
I pray therefore dear a gentle father
that doubts expound love to be two which
you reduce every good action
and its opposite wherever
you have told me in canto
17 really stone enough and that
virtual goes on explaining,
uh,
the theory that is very philosophical
theory that we have perceptions.
Your perception takes from our world
reality and impression and unfolded within
you. So it makes their mind
turn to it and whatever the,
the, the will is bound. That's
really what we call pleasure.
I'm paraphrasing.
Poorly are thy words and my following,
and excuse me,
let me just mention another
little passage now may be playing,
I get landline 35 now maybe playing to
the how hidden is the truth for those who
maintain that every love is in
itself, Praiseworthy. He's attacking.
This is the view of the PQ realtors who
believe that every pleasure without any
particular judgment attached to the
object of pleasure is praiseworthy.
Dante says, no, we have to exercise
some moral, uh, judgements.
We have to this day.
We have to create distinctions.
We have to discriminate between
the good and the bad love.
Perhaps built it's matter always seems
good, but not every stamp is good.
Even if it be good wax.
I would even go so far as to say that
he's really thinking now of his friend
Kevin Cantonese Weedo
epicurean. Now you, you saw,
he mentioned in Canada 12
by name epicurean leanings.
The idea that that's the piggery and
ethics that is pleasure is really the,
the,
the all new object worthy of any pursuit.
And uh,
that's really what we are doing whenever
we were in pursuit of knowledge or real
experiences, then they claimed
that all of our pleasure is, is,
is good.
Uh,
that's the Hellenistic ethics that
Dante really renounces or debates.
And then fact Virgil goes on saying they
words and my fallen with this is Dante
talking answered, have revealed the
nature of love to me, but are his,
made me more full of perplexity for
a flom is offered to us from without.
And if there's whole moves with
no other feet, it has no merit.
What it goes straight or crooked.
Now you say that everything is
love and the love that I have,
it depends on the experience of images.
I then what in what way?
How am I going to deserve for choosing
well or not choosing well since at that
at the basis of the imagination we have
perceptions and what I perceived maybe
looking good to me and
does not look good to you.
So the issue is displaced from the point
of the world of the imagination to the
world of perception and a virtual Gordon
explaining a scholastic theory to the
point that uh, indeed, uh, we, we, we, uh,
we incline to uh,
to the good but then actually we have
within us, uh, the Faculty of choice.
He says, ah, in order this will ever, they
may be conformed. There is innate in you,
the faculty,
which councils and which ought to hold
fifth threshold of a scientist talking
about once again our
freewill and he will add,
this is what I, this is online
60 and following a, and he led,
this is all I can tell you from a
philosophical point of view. Uh,
other issues about the freewill,
uh,
will be explained to you by Beatrice
when she first comes to you.
And so it would seem to make a distinction
between the knowledge they have
virtual and the knowledge of
a Beatrice. And he said, uh,
as far as reasons he's here can tell the
beyond that wait only for Beatrice for
it is a matter of faith and so on.
So there seems to be two ways of
understanding this issue. In fact, this,
the Beatrice will never
discuss this problem.
But in a sense Beatrice represents the,
the explanation explanation that Dante's
looking for because Beatrice is that
kind of love that for Dante that
stands for a visionary form of now of,
of love and not just a love that can be
reduced to a question of mechanics of
physics, of perception. Um, so, uh, uh,
that's the word can't wait.
Team seems to be doing then responds and
lodges and at the same time brings us
back into the very predicament that
cantos of 17 had a post for us.
Okay.
So seems that Dante's moving and at the
same time an impasse and other impasse
has been reached.
And now with this in mind,
we turn to what he unavoidably has to do
a chat to translate all of these issues
of love, imagination, um, uh,
choice from the theoretical into the
autobiographical or existential dimension.
This is done in the dream and erotic
dream that Dante relates at the beginning
of Canto 19.
Before it turns out that cancer,
I just want to tell you a but
how Dante understands this.
He has one line at the very end
of Kantar team that I would,
uh, the last line of country think
that I really want to, uh, uh,
underlying for you or the
whole paragraph reads.
Then when the shades were so far apart
from us that they could no longer be seen,
a new thought arose within
me from which others,
many and diverse were born.
And I rambled.
So from one to the other
that in my wondering,
my eyes closed and I changed my music
into dream and that empathy and that
introduces the dream of Canton,
I think.
But the line in Italian is really very
interesting because it presents the
connection between thinking and dreaming.
He says, in fact, it's installation.
My music, it's correct, but it's really
good to have said to make it very clear.
My thought, uh, Dante says one,
one line one 45, Could York,
he forgets a Rico Pairs El
Pensamiento in Sonia Trask Maathai.
So there's a kind of link I sort of sense
of the connection between thinking and
dreaming it.
Dante fevers dreaming at this point
over thinking you shouldn't be surprised
that dentists do invest the romance of
the rose at grant. Maybe we'll epic.
He said Dream and tells
the story of a dream.
The book of the Dutcher's
chicks of the chosen booker.
The Dutcher's is the story of a dream.
The Vita Nuova is full of dreams.
You know, even for those who are
interested in contemporary literature,
fairly contemporary, uh, I'm
thinking of kids, great poem,
sleep in poetry.
I don't know how many of you have a
chance to read that poet love sleeping
because sleep introduces the idea of the
dream and the possibility of a dream,
the possibility of a
knowledge which is not weld.
I finally have some revelations within me,
which is not what I would normally have
if I went away. Uh, so this is the,
the great privilege that they give to
dreams is the middle ages or the Middle
Ages really conscious of this dimension.
Yes,
that is a text by an author called macro
views. And if you want to know more,
I really, which is, uh,
uh, macro views who writes
on the dream of Skipio Cicero's
figure, uh, in the republic,
uh,
it's all about,
it's an encyclopedia of dreams and
the based on our terminal, Doris,
but it's, it's, it's, uh,
distinctions between Oracle's fantasies,
um,
insomnia, uh, uh, deliriums,
uh, dreams and so on.
So they are very conscious of the salt of,
of,
of power and, uh, revelations
that can come through dreams.
What is this dream about? It's now
definitely in the world of Acadia. Ah,
it's a dream. Let me just
read this, uh, initial, uh,
the beginning of Canto 19.
Uh,
I emphasize that this is now in auto
biographical or the highlighting of the
autobiographical dimension of all the
problems we have been discussing from 17 a
above all 16,
17 and 18.
Dante is to translate the
theories into a personal,
giving them a personal shape and the,
to,
to investigate that kind of importance
that they may have, uh, for him.
Uh, the, the, uh,
it starts then within the hour when the
day's heat over the earth and sometimes
by Saturn can no longer
temper the cold of the moon.
When the GM answers see the for two
Nemiah rise in the east before dawn by a
path which does not belong,
stay dark for it.
There came to me in dream a
woman stammering cross-eyed
and crooked on her feet
with maintenance and of sallow.
Whew.
I gazed at her and as the sand revives
called limbs be numbed by the night.
So my look gave her a ready tongue and
then in a little time made her quite
erect and Carlotta one
features as love desires.
When she hit her speech,
the set free,
she began to sing so that it would have
been hard for me to turn my mind from.
Ha I am she saying I am the sweet siren.
Who by beguile the sailors in mid sea,
so great delight it is to hear me.
I turned Ulysses eager on his way to my
song and he who dwells with me readily
departs so holy.
I contend him.
Her lips were not yet closed again.
When a lady holy and alert appeared
beside me to put her to confusion.
Oh, Virgil, Virgil, who is
this? She said with anger.
And He came with his eyes
fixed on their own rubber. One.
He sees the other and let her bear in
front tearing her clothes and showed me
her belly. They are woke me
that are woke me with a stench.
The stench that came from her.
I turned my eyes to the
good master three times.
At least I have called [inaudible].
He said, rise and calm.
Let us find the opening, but
which that enters. So that's the,
the end of the dream. The account of
the dream. And this is also the, uh,
uh, the Germany, uh, will,
uh, the journey will continue.
That seemed to have come to
a halt or here at night. Uh,
as you recall,
um,
just to give you a sense of
Dante's ordered poetic mind,
this is the second of three
dreams. Uh, you didn't,
we didn't really read the first
one about encanto canto nine.
Okay.
It was the dream of Ganymede.
The Dante's moving from the anti
purgatory, purgatory proper.
And then he said the third
one will appear in Canto 27.
So that really Dante is scanning these
three dreams with also sense of numerical
symbolic numerical position,
nine 18 retold in, uh,
in, in 19. But, uh, it takes place
during the night then and uh,
and, and uh, uh, 27. So
this is the, it's a dream.
It's a dream that I happens
at dawn of just some details.
And the dream at dawn has always the
value they believe that being a kind of
prophetic dream. I said, I
said, it's a dream that, uh,
really has assault of Hue, color of
the truth. He says something about,
so if, if you understand the
dream as an allegory for say,
uh, because it's, it's with about
veil, it's about tearing clothes.
There is something hidden underneath
it all. Uh, then it may he be our,
this allegory has a truth value.
It has,
it's not some kind of a mere fable.
Our aura that's,
um, Dante starts evoking
the planet Saturn, uh,
which is, uh, we shall
see that in a, you know,
the Dante mentioned planets and joins
them to the various liberal arts,
and probably have mentioned this before.
So when, when we'll be talking about,
say the moon, as anthis
going to discuss grammar, uh,
he'll talk about Mars,
the planet war,
and that he'll talk about music.
Jupiter injustice,
Saturn is astronomy. Uh, also the, the,
the planet of contemplation in the sense
I think that he's hinting that Slav is,
is, uh, the averse
side, the paddle day of,
of contemplation at different type of
self absorbed from nonetheless, no,
not that we've breaking
out to contemplation means
breaking out of oneself and,
and, and reach some kind of the
gates outside of time. Uh, here,
it's a dream that seems to be a
movement and an inward movement. Um,
so it Saturn and then he continues
with this language of astronomy and
divination are no longer temporary, called
to the moon. When the Geo Mansour's, uh,
see the for to pneumonia. This is our
processes of knowledges. Divination.
That's a different type of
rational knowledge dividing signs.
So this is the context in which the,
the,
the dream is set rises in
the east before dawn by path,
which has not long say dark for it.
There came to me in a dream,
not the dream starts.
And the first thing that I have to point
out to you is that in this, uh, uh,
in the dream,
the dreamer is an object.
The dream comes to him.
Clearly it is not real.
It's not something that
he decides he wants.
One is the object of some, some, uh, uh,
that's exactly the dreams or a so science
hemorrhages that descend into oneself
without one's own self control
or a dominion over them.
[inaudible] seems to place himself
in a condition of passivity,
which is the passivity of sloth.
Okay?
So the idea that I am awake and therefore
vigilant and therefore capable of
making judgments about what's happening
to me is here now for the time being
bracketed. Um, what is
this dream about? Oh, um,
what is a dream of a woman? And,
and, and the Italian text place,
since this is a dream of a two women,
two modes of being two choices,
it's almost as if he were, he isn't,
but you know, this is the [inaudible]
of Hercules at the side. Vega is,
they call him at the, at
the, at the, at the crossing,
the crossing road had to
choose between vice and virtue.
But Hercules is an easy time because he's
always going to the right as thinking
that in, in rethought graphy if you
go to the right, then you really have,
are going toward virtual,
you know, left and right. Vr,
dextrous and then sinister. You know,
the idea that left being a being bad,
the, but here we don't
have, that is two women.
But the language of the poem
distinguishes very carefully between them.
One is a family dinner.
There is in the materiality and living
in a kind of animals sense of the word.
And when the other woman appears,
she's called a [inaudible]. Ah,
the donor is the Italian word
from Domina. Uh, the lady,
uh, cold here, it's cold, Eh, Eh,
a holy,
a holy holy lady.
I guess I laid the holy and
the alert, et cetera. Uh, and,
and she is, uh, this is
this woman. Uh, she, uh,
crystallizes what we could call
the aesthetics of the ugly.
We always talking about the beauty and
the idea that beauty brings about a kind
of,
um,
revelation of love and the
pleasure that goes with beauty.
And in fact, uh, we can say that love,
no,
this is the platonic way of understanding.
Love is always a hunger
for beauty. Uh, so we,
the conventional way of thinking about
aesthetics is to imagine beautiful
proportionate forms he had.
Dante is giving exactly the opposite and
aesthetic of the ugly, but I, Natalie,
which is not static and somehow he's,
uh, experiences metamorphoses. In fact,
look what happens. She is
stammering, cross-eyed,
crooked on her feet.
She's the Anti Beatrice by obviously,
uh,
with main hands and sallow hue.
And now it changes from
the dreamer is an object.
The dreamer becomes a subject. I
mean, you see that from came to me.
And then I gazed at her
and as the survivors,
cold limbs Bynum by the night.
So my look,
my his desires transform this image
and from the ugly image that it was,
it becomes now instead
invested with attributes of
attractiveness and caught her
when features as love desires as love,
a prompt. And then this is what we
still don't understand who she is.
When she had the speech,
the set free,
she began to sing so that it would have
been hard for me to turn my mind from.
So the first thing the patient or we
know that they and, and the vehicle,
the temptation is the song.
This is also in primarily
a poetic temptation,
a certain way of understanding poetry.
It kind of even
meretricious form of poetry.
And what does she say she brings her?
She brings to center
stage the myth of Ulysses,
which has by now you always,
you know, uh, is the,
this steady temptation for
Dante is the point of reference.
To what extent is,
is on my own journey that I believe is
taking place under the aegis of divine
providence.
To what extent is it a form
of transgression and way
of going beyond boundaries
of breaking down or limits.
Because after all,
that's what you resisted in Canto 26 and
he knows what he has placed him but he
cannot get him out of his mind because
you listen stands or something powerful.
And what he stands for is the idea that
there is no knowledge worth heaven,
which is not connected
with transgressions, which
is not connected with,
with breaking down or barriers
and limitations in a way
because Dante is doesn't
do this thing. So, um,
accidentally when it comes
to Canto 26 or paradise,
he will see Adam and there is another
who is for him without a doubt,
a poet because it's the name giver
is the name, give her of the world.
He is the one who brings the
world into being through language.
And when Dante meets Adam,
there'll be some interesting details
that we can talk about there,
but I can anticipate this for you.
Adam is the one who has
understood transgression are
and that transcription or
for Adam appears as a source of growth.
It's not a fall for Dante said growth
said growth and understanding other types
of limitations because we cannot just
say that we, we, we care down all limits.
We tear down some limits
in our experience.
Adam test down and the, the,
uh, eats of the, the, the,
the fruit of the tree that had been
forbidden for him. Like a good son.
The father says, don't eat it, and he
goes and eats it and then he eats it.
He grows into a human being.
He discovers that the world is
not for him to be as a child,
then he has to have other experiences
of death, of maturity, of work,
et Cetera.
So there are ways in which we have to
understand this idea of breaking limits in
a different way from maybe the way I may
have conveyed it to you is none to here
is thinking of Ulysses and
anticipates the story of Adam. Uh,
there's a great temptation for Dante is
to believe that he to his journey is a
journey that enact Julissa's journey.
They Siren.
That's when she's telling him what she,
she's telling him is,
I made Julissa's happy. It's a, it's a
lie because we do know that you listen,
it's never really stopped off the
island of Capri in who's grotto.
This hiring is mythological.
He said to reside.
We do know that she, he did listen
to the song of the siren. Uh,
he made sure that his companions
would know and he hit himself bound
bound to the mast of the
ship. Okay? So that is,
that is a transgression and the
binding going on at the same time,
as I said at anyway. Uh, she
lies about, I turned Ulysses.
He got on his way to my song
and he who dwells with me.
So the first,
the other lie or the extension of the
lie is that the siren is making false
promises of happiness to the dream.
Where she's saying is,
you stay here with me and I am
the end of all that you desire.
I am going to give you all the pleasures
that you want and therefore your
journey may very well be over
if you are weary of the road.
This is the place where you should stop.
We have another figure that emerges
clearly the antagonist of the siren.
We don't know who she is.
We'll find out very quickly in Canto
30 and 31 cause the same scene will be
reenacted with the arrival of Beatrice.
We imagine that here too.
We have forced to imagine
that here too. She is, uh,
she's Beatrice,
her lips were not yet close again
when they lady wholly in the alert,
a woman in the sense
of, uh, uh, Damina, uh,
appeared beside me to put her to
confusion. Virgil Virgil is this,
she said with anger and he came with
what is the difference between them,
between these two women,
they are two different forms of poetry.
So now we understand why Dan had to been
talking about the imagination all along
because this is really what will introduce
him to the stakes in claiming to be a
poet.
This is what he's been talking about.
The actual faculty of himself as a poet
and the Cantos that will come 2122 to 26
and 27 constitute the most important
segment about ways of understanding
literary history, literary tradition, uh,
or the praise of originality within
that particular history and so on.
We are going to enter the
world of poetry more directly.
So they are two different women.
They speak to different voices.
One sweet meretricious and falls,
that's sweet song.
The other one very harsh who
says the journey is not over.
One forecloses the journey
of and the quest of Dante,
uh, be like, Ulysses,
I know that you want to be
like [inaudible] you can
stay here with me and I am
the end of all your
journeys and your quest.
The other one is claiming
exactly the opposite.
The journey has to continue
these two types of songs,
song or this hiring suite,
the chess,
also the stench of death attached to it,
the stench of the decomposition of
her body. And on the other hand,
a journey by this austere voice,
the voice of maybe their voice of love,
the voice of harshness. No, that then
just the language of, uh, of sweetness,
uh, is, is, uh, that have, uh, uh, uh,
love as an ongoing quest. That's what
she's saying. So two forms of love,
two forms of poetry,
two types of women,
the scene in case you're
interested in this.
How many of you I'm sure have
thought about it literally stages.
The, the, the,
the scene at the beginning of the
consolation of philosophy of breaches,
which in turn is thinking
about who internally,
thinking about the book 10
of the republic by Plato. Uh,
the idea of the place,
that place of love as the place of poetry
and philosophy changes that tradition.
This is not just poetry versus philosophy.
It's two different types of poetry.
Poetry can be also a philosophical poetry.
Poetry can be meretricious employed.
You can be also there.
There's sort of a rigorous,
severe form of investigation of one's
self and the world to different types of
poetry. Two different types of
loves to different types of women.
Which of the two is better?
How can we go on deciding that
one is better than the other?
Is there an objective pattern,
objective criterion by which you can say
Beatrice is actually better than this
hiring.
That's Dante.
Dante were of this idea of yes.
And the reason is going to be the foreign,
very simple,
the avoidance of death.
The Siren is the figure
that stands for that.
Underneath the pleasures of her language,
there is a stench that emanates from
then underneath that allegory. He,
Dante sees the danger of closing and the
danger of making the here and now and
the limitations of the here and now
and the limitations. So that song,
the end of his journey,
it's really a choice between an open
ended quest and the foreclosure of the
siren.
This is the only way in which you can
objectively believe that there is a
hierarchy between these two
loves in between these two women.
Um, we, we moved to Canto, Ah,
21 and 22.
Um,
but I'm wondering if I shouldn't take a
few questions here about this cancer, um,
uh, on any other problems before we
move on to something a little bit more,
a little bit different.
Um, more classical,
the encounter between stations and Virgil.
So let me see if there are some questions
now about this, this face, this, uh,
this cantors,
uh,
or would you like to meet to go on and
then maybe we can come back to them.
Very good you say that,
but
the question is excellent.
I was supposed to draw some
connection between this scene and,
and,
and the,
and the scene of Cassela in
Canto to above all of purgatory.
I call it excellent because I
agree you're supposed to and,
and it's the reappearance and the
different guises, the same computation,
how the aesthetic can become a,
both a way of gathering people
at, on this health. Oh, that,
that's the famous story of Cassela
the power of the song just collects,
gathers,
but at the same time,
it endusers assault to
forgetfulness of uh, uh,
whatever purposes those souls are
supposed to entertain and carry out.
The difference of course,
is that it's the same story here.
Now the differences is not between,
let's say a castle,
a UN and others with, with
the language of a, of Cato.
Here,
it's more an an autobahn directly.
We are moved into the
consciousness of the pilgrim.
We have entered this as deep as
we can into his unconscious mind.
This is the moment of what he's,
he comes to an,
an amazing self revelation
that had the story of,
because Ella had the
ring of public discourse,
poetry as a public act,
um,
gathering a number of people around it.
So this is a very good,
that's a thank you for mentioning
that. And by the way, uh,
I don't know that we never probably
read it, but if you read the beginning,
I think I read it in Italian
for professor Brookshire's.
I know she likes the province, our
song, but the beginning of Canto eight,
uh, also that moment of
the nostalgia for the, the,
the safety of home, uh, the
weariness of the evening,
the evening song, uh, et Cetera,
that that represents another version of
the same kind of a dilemma with which
the pilgrim is a confronted.
Okay.
Maybe we can come back to some
of this since we move into this,
literally is the segment
of the poem. I said 21, uh,
22, uh, going through 20, 23, 24,
a, which is really, uh,
has poetry now as, uh,
it's, uh, the subject matter
and Nantais begins with, um,
um,
let's say the classical tradition,
the relationship between an encounter
that takes place. We are in the,
in the world of avarice
and product galaxy,
the encounter between stations
and Virgil as you know,
stages views himself as
a disciple or Virgil.
And in many ways,
he challenges Virgil's ideology.
Virgil's thought was virtual
can go on writing a poem,
the Aeneid and EC logs,
which are about the,
the, the pastoral world
or the Geologix. You know,
this world about the cultivation of the
earth where virtual appears that he's
most anti or fic he distinguishes and the
distances himself from the traditional
fuse,
the poet of mad love,
who descends into the depths of hades.
Uh, and of course, it's a waylaid by,
by the mad love for a,
you read this and is the way of
conquering death through the song.
He believes that through by singing,
he can bend, uh, the loss of a,
of death and therefore gain immortality.
Uh,
Virgil opposes a world of, uh,
of, of work. The world of, uh,
of, of mature. The responsible
world of, of a knee is, uh,
uh, the, the, the,
the hero who is so divided against himself
and yet managers to always find his
way around, you know, and, uh,
and this kind of regularly
erratic path, uh, of, uh,
of his epic, uh, stages,
uh, counters, Virgil,
uh, stations writes the Tobias, he writes
another look. We, she never finished.
And another little epic called the, the,
the Achillea the story about Achilles,
but he'd the only a fragment
he writes the turbine,
which really goes against
those claims of virtual,
or he retrieves a Mexican junction
between tragedy and the epic,
uh, the world of, uh,
the world of Jocasta.
And he depose the monstrosity of
that world, the world of up Polynese,
uh, and the [inaudible]
the world of Antigony, uh,
cast in as a kind of nightmarish world.
It's literally the most
psychological of these epics,
the wars that happened
in the mind. And, and,
and this idea of a monstrosity of human,
our fate and human desires.
Uh, and, and so that,
these are the two worlds that Dante
wants to bring together in this little
appeal. And I would call it a opinion,
is a Greek word, meaning a literal epic.
This is a transcriptional to epic,
Texas gathered into one and
two elliptical form. And,
and he has a tough,
tough task because what he wants to show
is the possibility of harmonizing the
two of them.
And he shows how the two of
them really go talk as friends,
friends across time. Of course, uh,
Stasia's lives around the year 17.
Aidy Virgil dies in the year 19. Um, um,
another friends because poetry has managed
their poetry, has made, made them up.
The poetry of, of Virgil has made them
friends and, and, and stations is,
is, is a sort of a classical
version of Dante himself.
Dante's the disciple virgin,
so was stations. So he has
to bring them together.
But as soon as the pressure of making
them agree only is because they're two
different visions. That in and of
itself may not be all that difficult.
Stations is very skeptical
about, uh, uh, the empire.
Virgil is not all that skeptical.
It's possible to read the Aeneid and see
that there's a lot of ambiguity in the
way which he, he talks about
about, uh, Augustus and the empire,
but it's basically writing the epic that
justifies the ideology of the empire.
That is a difficulty between them,
is that Dante said the real difficulty
and challenge for Dante is that he has to
try to understand how stages start to
adjust Stasia's vision of monstrosity to
some idea of the sacred.
This is the real challenge.
This is the difference that Dante
has from the classical world.
How do we understand the sacred and
in what way is it's impossible to use
Stasia's Virgil as he already did
with Cato, who is, by the way,
they the hero of Lucas third
poet of this epic tradition.
Virgil Lucan stages.
How's it possible to
see in these texts of,
of stages the seeds of something good?
How can we build anything
good out of this, um,
vision of heroes and characters
who just fornicating with, uh,
with her own fantasies,
who cannot really get out of there are
of their minds who just are discover
their own,
um,
and changing submission to a
force that's nonsense to fate.
It's really absolutely a different
worldview from the world of virtual.
So let me just go on a
little bit with that. At 21,
I just, uh, um, talking,
first of all with a
Dante begins, um, with,
uh, um, an allusion to, um,
this natural thirst, natural
thirst, which is this world of, uh,
of their actual thirst for knowledge.
It's really much the world of the banquet.
There were the virustotal. We have this
incredible thirst for knowledge. And then,
uh, uh, uh, uh,
this figure called
stations appears. Uh, um,
we also being told that
nature, the natural world, uh,
is, uh, mysteriously shaking.
There's an earthquake because every
time that I sold gets liberated from the
purgatorial, uh, experience
or expiation, uh, the,
this purification and expiation.
Then the,
the mountain trembles and they, and, and,
and stages can go on with them up
to the garden of Eden. And, uh,
and then, um, uh, stages, uh,
reveals himself and he will
say, and unlined 60, um,
uh,
and I who have laid in this pain 500
years or more Statia speaking felt.
But now my will free for the better
threshold there for thousands feel the
earthquake.
And here the devout spirits to the
mountain ran the praises to the Lord,
sued that his erection is taking place.
And this is going to be the
resurrection of stages. And virtual. Uh,
it's a stages but also virtual in
their own, their own vision. Uh,
so he goes on describing himself
and the time when the good titles,
the emperor he's evoking
at the time of the, uh,
he's recalling the time
that the destruction of the
temple in Jerusalem at the
time when the good titles by helping
with the king most high avenged, uh,
justice,
divine mysteries of justice,
the wounds from which poured the blood
sold by Judas replied, the spirit,
I boy Yonder, they name that
most end users. And donors.
Most famous indeed,
but still without faith stations.
A Pagan, uh, uh, really
born again. Now this is a,
the born again pagan, uh,
that, uh, appears in this, uh,
uh, in, in this camp.
So sweet was my spirit of song
that Rome drew me roam drum.
It's, they, it's an interesting, ah,
images. It's really speaking of, uh, uh,
roam, having a kind of power that usually
we linked with love with, with desire.
You know, the, the pool of desire.
Rome brought him to it, to, uh,
to herself, a to loosen without
going into that to itself.
And then I was worthy to have my brown
and my brows adorned with myrtle men
young still speak my name,
which is stages.
And I sang of Thebes and then have a
great achilles, but fell by the way,
with the second burden, uh,
he, he could never complete.
The second text, and I'll look at the
way he speaks about poetry. Spoke,
speaks through sparks as a kind of fire.
Sparks at kindles the fire
in me where from the divine,
a flame,
the divine flame from which more
than a thousand have been lit.
I mean the Aeneid.
So that's,
that's already poetry now
is invested with power,
the power to
light the fire in the
readers and in its followers,
which was important. My mother and
my nurse, uh, without it, I have no,
I had not weighed a dram and have
lived yonder and Virgil lived.
I would have contented to a sand from
then more than I was due before coming
forth from banishment.
So the two metaphors to speak of poetry,
one is that of the sparks of fire.
And the second one is that of nourishing
the inner hunger mother and nurse.
It's, it's, it's a nursing,
the nursing of, uh,
of his readers.
So a great acknowledgement of the
master without his knowledge that,
that, uh, it is Virgil to whom
he's speaking and then came to 21,
which is,
and another image that may remind
you of the story of [inaudible],
um, stages reveals Dante
reveal stations, identity,
a virtuous identity.
It's Restasis and they try to,
uh,
the two of them tried to embrace already.
He was bending to embrace lines one
third and following my teacher's feet.
But he said to me, brother,
do not. So for that word,
the shade and the shade,
thou seest and he rising.
Now Thou canst understand the measure
of the love that Burns and me for the,
when I forget her
emptiness in three chains,
assorted things and mistake
that has been made before.
And the mistake that I think,
uh, is, uh, is meant to, um,
to convey the,
the claims of the illusions of poets
to believe that there is some kind of
solidity to them and not just
to the poetry, to the works,
but a solidity to them
that then this embrace, uh,
belies no solid family as
a kind of emptiness is a
sort of distance between the
poets and their works. This
is not going to, I think,
interfere very much because it's the works
the works of art that we are going to
be talking about. And
we in, in Canton 22. Uh,
so the,
uh,
the two poets now are our
self, uh, in in a good note,
each an acknowledgement of the other
and they go on talking about line 10 and
following, um, uh,
Virgil asks stages to explain to him
why this moral blight existed at him,
why they scene of avarice. Um, why
the scene of Alvarez. And he says,
this is the passage love cantor 22 lions
12 and following love kindled by virtue
always kindles and other.
That's the salt of
vitality and power of love.
It's not self enclosed.
It's one that goes on, uh,
creating and propagating itself
has a generosity of its own.
Okay. Has a kind of charitable ness of
it. So if only it's flame appear without.
So fire and love seem to be
conjoined by this common,
uh, element, that common, uh,
element of the power of
propagation or perpetuation.
Um, uh, from the hour. Therefore,
when juvenile descended among us in the
limbo of hell and made their affection
known to me, my goodwill toes,
the was as great has ever held.
Any one for a person not seen so that
now the stairs will seem short to me,
but tell me and there's a friend,
forgive,
give me if with too much assurance has
slackened the rain and there's a friend
speak with me now.
How could avarice find a
place in depressed along
with so much wisdom is by the
zeal thou was filled with um,
this is a passage of
some, uh, some importance.
The because first of all the
claim of friendship between the,
from Virgil,
he's moved by the show friendship on the
part of stations as let's talk now as,
as friends.
Um,
friendship is an ethical
virtue as you know, in uh,
artists thought was ethics and for
Cicero writes a treatise called on
friendship,
which done mentioned at the beginning
of his philosophical texts in the belief
that friendship is really
the other language.
The other term for philosophy or it's
the friend and the philosopher are
interchangeable.
This is if there is,
there is a love of in friendship and
there's a level of truth that is the I,
that is the idea.
There is some exaggeration on the part
of virtual because there is really a
friendship implies to some kind of some
degree of equality, right? You must have,
in order to be friends, you must
have some idea, we call it in fact,
it's usually said that tyrants and slaves
are not capable of love or friendship
because both since one is
the version of the other,
both really have a kind of uh,
uh, uh, inequality vis a VI.
The other, the slave is by
definition inferior. They
tyrant thinks he's superior.
So friendship remains a kind of
equality and this is a little bit of an
exaggeration because there is no equality
between stages instead of Toric or
exaggeration stages. And
Virgil Virgil is, um, uh,
I acknowledge as being superior to stages
stage of sees himself as a disciple
and therefore views Virgil as
superior from a poetic point of view,
from a theological point of view.
Stages is superior to Virgil was,
stations is going on to paradise and
virtual is going to go back to limbo.
So there is a kind of, uh, uh, the,
the, uh, it push in the, in the,
in the direction of a wishful thinking
may be on the, on the part of,
on the part of Virgil. I must also
add that Dante said, uh, kind of, uh,
some were closer to do about him.
He may be aware that the friendship was
never really thought of as a Christian
virtue.
It's a classical impaled and virtue and
because it really confuses, you know,
it's the idea is a friend is
always part of one soul. Uh,
it's really an earthbound. They said
it's, it's a north bound up, uh,
experience.
So it was always the thought,
not Augustan Augustan who has a friend,
I leap years and feels responsible
for our repairs. But by and large,
it was this idea that the,
the friendship could
distract the mind from, uh,
from an assent to a
higher and superior ends,
parodies, Yak excesses, uh, and pleasures.
So not, they must be aware that there
were efforts to Christianize this,
this idea. Nonetheless, it,
it brings the conversation
between them back to the earth.
Uh,
and they talk as if there were two friends
really meeting in the forum and the
Agora and chatting about their moral
failings or their own poetic crafts and
visions.
How could you find the,
how could you be so avaricious when you
were so enlightened in so many other
ways? That's the question. STASIA's
responses is not avaricious.
And I think that that adds a great
deal about their understandings,
the misunderstandings of each other,
but also their understanding. So poetry,
he goes on talking about the fact
that he is prodigal all the time.
So then, so say, uh, that he, uh,
you may remember from Kantar several
of fair knew the difference between the
avaricious and, and the sense of
practicality that product quality was, eh,
Eh,
a,
a violation of the economy
of goods by devaluing,
by getting of devaluing them,
not holding on to them.
The avaricious overvalues
the goods and tries to,
to heap amass a larger
quantities of goods.
So he goes on,
uh,
really thinking stages once to make it
clear for at least 40 lines about the
fact that he's, uh, he was prodigal
and w we have to understand what,
why he would say that.
And then in fact,
he goes on acknowledging once again,
stations focus, moral conversion.
So that's the first thing about
what poetry can do. She says no,
then that iris was too far removed from
me and this access thousands wound have
punished,
have punished and head.
I had it not been that are corrected my
ways when I understood the lines where
as if in rage,
human nature that it's cry to what occurs.
Hunger for gold that's down or
drive the appetite of mortals.
I should be rolling the weight and know
that this small jousts but he's saying
is that he read a passage in a book,
three of the Aeneid the story that we
already saw or poorly Doris who had been
killed because of a,
they want to rob him of
his gold and, uh, uh,
stages reach the moral conversion.
Um,
I like this a lot we can say about this
lines the first of all, first of all, um,
I think this exemplifies
how we actually read.
We read them with this member,
the integrity of the text.
We take out of a book out of a
passage that which will we find,
um, uh, relevant to us. Um,
and he takes some blinds, uh,
in, in, in, in their only,
take some lines from the book,
three of their need.
He also alters the meaning,
the original text.
The virtuous says exactly the opposite.
To what though,
why do you not contain, uh, the, the, uh,
why do you not contain the hung
the appetite of mortals or sacred,
sacred,
a hunger for gold,
which the text and says curse. It's the
word sacred, which Dante is using here.
Why do you know,
uh,
contain or sacred fame of gold
or sacral assignment that loader,
they wouldn't sacred. As you
probably know, some of you may know.
It means two things.
It's symbols,
some biggest term that
you semantically speaking,
because you can describe both that which
we call the holy and that which we call
the profane.
He joins them together.
There's no clear cut distinction between
the pro foundational blasting on the
other hand or the sense of holiness.
So I can understand why my translation,
Saint Claire,
I'm a translator, uh, decides to
choose the cursed instead of a,
call it secret. For instance, cursed,
he's dismembering his taking one,
one side or what is it?
Much more complicated version of the
meaning of the word. So that's one thing,
but the poetic text of Virgil has a
moral power over and against Virgil's own
intentions.
We can understand now retrospectively,
why dentists to distinguish between
poets and the works. That's,
you know, we can read the works regardless
of the intentions of the others.
And we can, we can select or
take out a of those texts,
whatever we think that we were.
However we think that they speak to us.
And then he goes on,
uh, uh, describing
his poetic growth. Now
this is lines, uh, uh,
55 now went down to sing. The crew
alarms, the Double Wolf Jocasta,
the double wars children,
a ticklish and colonies in the tragic and
that big text called the suburban said
the singer of the BW colleagues.
So see that's already the opposition.
Virgin now appears as
the author of a pastor,
a poem that your colleagues were a
rivalries are always going to be placated.
That is the big colleagues of the pastoral
are virtues are always about rivalry.
Rivalry between two shepherds,
which,
which of us they ask is the better singer,
which of us is the better poet.
And that is always,
there is never any tragic outcome.
There's some, some, some uneasiness,
some anxiety between uh,
running through that kind
of debate between the posts.
But it's not the rivalry of joke of,
of Polynesians [inaudible] so that's,
that's really the difference that
Dante is highlighting between them.
And then it continues.
It does not appear by the nodes,
which clear touches with the,
so the college and other hand,
the Cleo is the muse of history.
So cleo is the muse for history
is the world of Stasia's.
That's a faith yet made the faithful
without which we're doing is not enough.
If that is so what son or what candles
dispelled I darkness so that thereafter
it's lift the sales,
be fine,
be behind the fishermen.
Now we know that what he's really asking
in a general way is the relationship
between poetry and faith.
How could stages we know how he
reached this moral conversion.
Now we have to be told somehow,
how did he go on finding a faith?
What is the relationship
between the two of them?
Can poetry reveal and lead us
on to the world of faith or not?
Uh,
and stage two says already,
that's really the answer that he will
provide. And the other ends with him.
Thou first directed me to
Parnassus the mountain of poetry.
So that poetic experience,
the poetic apprenticeship is the preamble
to the experience of faith to drink in
its caves.
A metaphor that picks up the natural
thirst of the previous canter to drink and
escapes.
And the first,
after God enlightens me
that didn't like him,
that goes by night and carries the light
behind him and does not help himself.
But makes wise those who follow
when they'll say in a moment,
we'll see what he said. But the
metaphor is that of really, uh, uh,
virtual is a prophetic voice who speaks,
but that the language he uses
like the law, the, the, uh,
a lamp that he carries on his back for
the benefit of those who follow and
himself clearly remains the dark.
That's what he said.
The age turns new again.
Justice comes back and the primal years
of men and the new race descends from
heaven. This is the famous
fourth Eq Rog of Virgil.
Virgil is a celebrating the birth of a
child polio and around this birth of a
child. He's also talking about
the rejuvenation of the world.
Uh,
it's an emblem.
Polios birth is an emblem for this
Pythagorean vision that he has a vision
whereby the world goes
through a 360,000 years of,
uh, the Golden Age, the
silver age and so on,
and then degrades itself and goes right
back to where it started. Epitaph,
librarian,
vision of a metamorphosis and
the circulation of the universe.
It's the full deck log.
Um, um, interestingly,
this also crystallizes that which is the
fundamental issue of Virgil's vision.
The concern with birth,
the concern with the fact of being born,
that the fact of being born has
within itself the potential to renew,
uh, the world to affect the world and
change the direction of the world.
And then he, we know that he'll
say, and there was soap here, uh,
because we are coming to the
end of the period through the,
I was a poet through the Christian,
but thou that thou may see
better where the outline,
I should set my hand to color it
already. The world was, uh, everywhere.
Big pregnant Italian says with the true
faith sown by the messengers and so on.
He's going to talk how the world outside
only batteries that reinforced the
message of faith that he had
found in the fourth Techlog. Okay.
The four deck will be seen
as a messianic ecolog, uh,
but outline that makes it
transition from poetry to face.
I was a poet through Leah. I was
a poet through the, uh, Christian.
I think it really makes it necessary for
us for linger on it for a little bit.
First of all, the line has what
we call an Anaphora through the,
through the, I was a poet, I was
poured through the Christian.
This is the same line,
uh,
that says [inaudible] the Italian
word line 74 [inaudible] 73 per tape.
Wait a fully bestech Christiana,
the Anaphora.
It gives continuity to the movement
of the line from poetry to faith.
But nonetheless, if you read
this slide carefully in Italian,
you see that there is
also a sub genre for a,
you know what I mean by
[inaudible] fallen in the middle,
a break per tape with a food break,
birthday,
Christiana,
the line gives,
has a mobility that seems to a promise,
that transition from poetry to face,
but at the same time,
technically it forces you to stop as if
they were to discontinuous experiences.
You cannot go from one world of
poetry to the one world of faith.
You can go from one world of
politics, one world of faith. This,
that ambiguity of poetry is exactly
what they are trying to retrieve.
So,
but did I say here to the about this,
this issue of stage shows and virtual
stages is dealing with the tragedy of
birth.
Virgil deals with,
with optimistically about the history
making our quality of the event of birth.
That is at the same time a desire to
establish a sense of what is the sacred,
I will try to discuss with you,
um,
Lolita,
how poetry is now invested
with the kind of sacredness,
the ambiguous sense of the
world has both the profane and,
and, and the holy within it. Uh,
it's an, it's, it's, it's a hybrid.
And this,
this is hybrid that would allow Dante to
assimilate a stations vision to his own
understanding of history and the sacred.
So let me stop here and see
if there are questions. Um,
please.
It seems like it's more common for Dante
to be the one to ask for their stories.
I, is this the only place that Virgil was
the one who asked the question or like
what is this?
Well, the, the, the virtual is the, uh,
the question is,
it seems that usually it's Dante
who interviews the people he meets.
And, but here in Canto
21 and 22, it's Virgil.
And is that the case? And if it's
true, why would that be the case?
The answer is that that's not really
true. Bills in the candle, Ulysses,
it is he who is this Virgil who speaks
you remember to two years it's virtual.
So it's virtual in Ulysses.
It's has really more to do with the
figures of the classical world that seemed
to be in this case virtual system
best indicated for a status as he,
as he was for Virgil. Since you're
interested in this kind of, uh, of, um,
uh, aspect of the dramatization of
the poem, I would mention to you,
for instance, their candles in fair. No,
we didn't have a chance to talk about
them where the Virgil would completely
abandon Dante's as well. You go here,
I don't want to be with you. Uh,
you, you go and, and, and own your own,
carry out this introduction without,
I wait for you here.
And that happens for instance,
in the Canto of fraud, the,
the, the, and, and usury.
Um,
it,
this is if Dante had something to
better understand on his own, uh,
without Virtua's presence. But
usually that is the way in which, uh,
the style of a, of the
presentation takes place. So who,
who is most apt, uh, in the
case of the classical figures,
the classical poet speaking
to a classical. Okay.
Yeah.
Comment a little further on
the significance of Contra 19.
It looks like we're kind of reenactment of
the fall of Adam and eve.
It's,
it's almost a bit this woman even in the,
in the dream,
the siren. Yes. And the dream it when she,
mmm.
She brings forth the,
this promise of happiness and it's
really accurate wing that the promise of
Lucifer of this narrow,
I will make you like God.
Why is this sort of,
um,
why is this theme of,
of sort of the atom theme
coming up here in 19?
Is there some sort of
strand that I'm missing?
The Youtube, the question
is that, um, uh, Susan,
Ken until 19,
in the dream of this hiring,
there is an echo of,
uh,
the fall of Adam more than Lucifer.
I would say the fall of Adam and Andy,
why would there be,
uh, that, uh, if that's true,
why would that be the echo?
And my answer is I haven't, I didn't
catch it. I did. I never caught this,
uh, uh, echo of Adam
there. Um, it's an it,
it's actually the story of, uh, uh,
the temptation of this woman
fish. That's where she is, right?
They've decided marine,
uh,
who wants to use
forgetfulness in the pill.
The is really a classical figure.
Um,
I would say that I sort of
resist the hearing here,
the figure of a,
in the figure of Adam,
because Adam doesn't
really talk about falling.
Say this is a danger for the
pilgrim who he's, he's a, he's a,
he's a dramatizing his sense of,
uh,
of yielding,
surrendering his will to the seduction,
the seductive song of the siren.
Adam I'm with,
and this is stove love. Without them,
a stories becomes one of knowledge. Uh,
it's a little bit different.
Uh, they may be echoes. I'm not,
I'm not going to be so,
so firm and say, no,
there's no heck of that. Does that.
But I didn't, I didn't, I didn't, it,
I didn't feel the necessity for
that action for my argument.
Well, maybe I'm answering my own question
here, but wouldn't you say that the,
the theme of knowledge and transgression
runs through both the dream sequence
that Dante has
and the story of Adam's fall,
I mean, is, is, is there, um,
that theme where you list is,
you know,
wanted to sort of gain this knowledge
is experience of hearing the siren song,
right. And, um,
and to gain that knowledge
he had to sort of transgress.
And isn't that what the siren
represents? I mean, you say,
you said he keeps coming back
to this theme of you list.
He does.
He doesn't mention the store down
connection really comes in because Adam's
ultimately ate the fruit for knowledge.
Well,
I indicated that the,
the story of Adam in Kendall 26,
uh,
it retrospectively illuminates what's
happening in Canto 26 of him fair.
And that he tool, uh, experience,
understands knowledge and, and, and,
and, and transgression that they,
that they go hand in hand and that it's
difficult to impossible to separate them.
And that's the story of Ulysses.
Dante does feel that he is
and they said dangerous.
A temptation for him to believe that
he's, he's, uh, he's like, you listen.
Whereas he has no problem later in when
he understands what the story of Adam is
in thinking in acknowledging that
Adam is the arch port, you know,
we're all reinventing the
world, et Cetera. Uh, so,
uh, I will say that there
are three figures here.
You listen as Adam and Dante and,
but the relation between them is never
what was one of full of identification on
the part of Dante with either, uh, you
know, he comes, he approximates them, uh,
and somehow also pulls away
from, from both. He's not really,
Adam is not the arch poets who names
the world and there's not really you
listeners that fear that
he may be like you races,
which is a more dangerous, uh, uh,
since sense that he has that
we'll continue more openly, uh,
as he goes on the story
of Adam, uh, you know,
it's going to be picked up in the
garden of Eden, the Garden of Eden.
Of course there is the idea
that we lost the garden. Uh,
but Dante is not one to be
in that garden anyway. Uh,
when he comes to the garden of Eden,
he identifies it with a lot of things.
Uh,
the really nostalgia for the
mother. Um, and, and he doesn't,
he understands that his to grow up,
he has to get out of that fantasy.
I don't know if, uh,
uh, you know, this is,
yeah. Um, what confuses
me, I guess that, um,
you know, the, the siren here,
the dream secret seems to be wanting
to halt Dante is west his journey for
yes,
absolutely.
And yet with respect to Ulysses,
the siren seem to represent the opposite
in the sense that his interaction with
her was, um, uh,
was something where he was trying to go
past the balances to gain knowledge and
gain experience of hearing her.
Uh,
so I'm trying to draw the
connections in my mind for what,
what is really Dante trying
to tell us with this sequence.
Why does he go back to this,
um,
this reference of the sirens, this
reference to the siren. I mean,
maybe you could just summarize, I guess
maybe it would help clear it up. Um,
what she represents to Dante here in
Canton 19 versus what she represents to
Ulysses.
Yeah. Good. What's a, what does
the siren represent? Very briefly,
what does this hiring represent
to Dante and to Ulysses?
What is the difference to Dante?
This Shireen represents the,
the lure of death.
He understands a beneath that,
that promises of yield to the here and
now and to my voice that is really,
uh, there's said nothing in this and
he's attracted to that nothingness.
That's really what it is for Ulysses.
She also represents the extraordinary,
uh,
enchantment of the song that would lead
them to death because that's, that's,
that's what it happens to all those who
listened to this, Irene, you listen,
wants to hear it and bind himself so that,
that does not yield all
together to her call. That's,
that's how I can put it.
Thank you. We'll see you.